Tomaten sind das beste Gemüse unter dem
Himmel und wenn du sie im Topf anbaust
findest du bestimmt noch ein ungenutztes
Fleckchen auf dem du so eine Pflanze
hier unter bekommst und dann ganz viele
leckere Früchte ernten kannst aber was
muss man beachten damit das auch was
wird mit der dicken Ernte da gibt es
einiges und wir fangen am besten beim
Topf an denn damit steht und fällt ein
gutes Stück von deinem Tomaten erfolgt
was viele Leute missachten ist dass das
Wurzelwerk ein ziemlich elementarer
Bestandteil einer Pflanze ist vielleicht
weil die Wurzeln ja unter der Erde
wachsen und man sie normalerweise gar
nicht sieht als ich vor zehn Jahren
angefangen habe Gemüse im Kübel
anzubauen musste ich auch auf die harte
Tour lernen dass der Topf das zu Hause
unsere Balkonpflanzen ist und wie heißt
das zu Hause ist kein Ort sondern ein
Gefühl wie auch immer ich glaube das
Gefühl in so einem winzigen Topf
eingefärbt zu sein in dem sich die
eigenen Wurzeln auf der verzweifelten
Suche nach mehr Platz eine Runde nach
der anderen um sich selbst treu ist eher
unschön und führt sicher nicht dazu dass
man als Pflanze über sich hinauswächst
also bevor es jetzt noch dramatischer
wird der Topf für eine Tomatenpflanze
sollte ca 20 Liter groß sein wenn das
bei dir platztechnisch nicht drin ist
dann gibt es auch so mini balkonsorten
die man sogar in den Blumenkasten
anbauen kann aber ein ausreichend großer
Topf hilft nichts wenn man ihn mit der
falschen Erde füllt also was ist die
beste Erde um richtig kräftige Pflanzen
großzuziehen ich habe einmal sehr gute
Erfahrungen mit ausgereiftem Kompost
gemacht und dann auch mit torfreier Bio
gemüseerde es gibt auch spezielle
Tomaten Erde das wäre natürlich am
idealsten und weil Tomaten so hungrig
sind sprechen wir als nächstes über
meine geheime Dünger Mixtur wir füllen
jetzt unseren Topf zu einem Drittel mit
Erde und dann schnappe ich mir einmal
Urgesteinsmehl und als zweiten
Bestandteil Hornspäne alternativ würde
auch einen schafwolldünger gehen rein
und die beiden Sachen mische ich zu
gleichen Teilen passt dabei auf dass ihr
das staubige Gesteinsmehl nicht einatmet
und von dieser Mischung gebe ich dann 3
Esslöffel in den Topf und verknete das
richtig gut mit der Erde die wir eben
eingefüllt haben aber bevor wir die
Tomate jetzt einpflanzen können
unterziehen wir die noch meiner kleinen
Behandlung einmal lockere ich den
Wurzelballen immer ganz leicht auf damit
die Pflanze im Topf schneller anwächst
und dann entferne ich auch die unteren
Blätter der Pflanze ab in den Topf damit
und seht ihr das durch das Entfernen der
Blätter können wir die Pflanze noch
tiefer einsetzen und so bildet sie neue
Wurzeln an dem Teil des Stängels der
dann unter der Erde liegt und das führt
dann dazu dass unsere Pflanze viel
stabiler steht dann den Topf mit Erde
auffüllen leicht andrücken und alles gut
angegießen so dass das Wasser die Erde
an die Wurzeln spült und die kleinen
Hohlräume unter der Erde geschlossen
werden aber Vorsicht der Umzug ins neue
Topf zu Hause ist noch nicht komplett
vollzogen so würde die Pflanze nämlich
wenn sie etwas größer ist einfach
umkippen also muss ein Stab als Stütze
her ich nehme dafür zum Beispiel
Bambusstäbe aber es geht auch jeder
andere Stab der stabil genug ist und
möglichst zwei Meter lang ist und wir
sind immer noch nicht fertig umgezogen
denn jetzt musst du deine Pflanze noch
an den Ort bringen wo sie später wachsen
soll das sollte ein möglichst sonniger
Fleck auf deinem Balkon oder in deinem
Garten sein weil Tomaten nämlich
richtige Sonnenanbeterinnen sind und
weil Tomaten eine ziemlich fiese
Krankheit bekommen können wenn ihre
Blätter nass werden es ist die
gefürchtete Kraut und Braunfäule ist es
am besten wenn du sie überdacht oder
zumindest geschützt direkt an der
Hauswand anbaust Tomaten sind ganz
schöne Mimosen und wenn du wissen willst
welche Aufgaben in den nächsten Wochen
und Monaten bei deinen Tomaten anstehen
dann verlinke ich dir hier drüben das
passende Video also geh raus und macht
die Welt ein bisschen grüner grüß mir
deine Tomatenpflanzen und wir sehen uns
im nächsten Video wieder bis dann
tschüss